last friday texas lieutenant governor
dan patrick vowed to end tenure for
public university professors who teach
critical race theory in their classrooms
he tweeted we banded in publicly funded
k-12 and we will ban it in publicly
funded higher ed
that is just one of the most recent
examples of white americans refusal to
educate students about the advantages of
being white in this country well
if they won't let schools teach that
lesson then i guess i'll have to teach
it right here right now in a little
segment called the
abcs of white privilege
[Music]
there's a lot to learn so let's get
started a is for assimilation
assimilation is when people of color
have to adjust natural things about
themselves to make white people
comfortable this includes code switching
straightening our hair and saying the
beetles are good i'm sorry they stink
and they're not cute
b
is for band-aids being nude and not just
band-aids did you know that until
recently black dancers couldn't find
tights or ballet shoes that match their
skin tone
the only options available to them were
nude but who's nude is that that's not
what i look like naked i look like this
[Applause]
c
c is for colonization europeans came to
north america and stole this land from
indigenous people but we've been taught
that europeans were brave explorers when
the only thing they actually discovered
was syphilis
wow that that was great i think the
audience learned a lot d is for the doll
test
oh
there's more there is more tarik
the doll test in the 1940s doctors
kenneth and mamie clark conducted a test
in which black children were presented
with dolls of different colors their
studies showed that most children
attributed positive characteristics to
white dolls because of societal
perceptions sad right but if you ask me
barbie wishes she was as fly as christy
e is for emotional tax now they should
call that [ __ ] physical tax because i
have broken my back dragging white
people into the light and i'm sick of it
it takes its toll emotionally oh that's
where it comes from f is for being
followed around stores i'm looking at
you walgreens
g is for gerrymandering the act of
manipulating congressional boundaries in
favor of a specific political party
otherwise known as racist tetris
oh wow you really did the whole alphabet
h is for something we can't get good
health care black women are three to
four times more likely to die from
pregnancy-related causes than white
women just because they're black and
that's just pregnancies you know they're
everything else
i is for implicit bias now that's when
we attribute stereotypes without our
conscious knowledge here's an example
crossing the street when you see a black
eye but not when you see a white guy
even though both men can and will kill
you dead and that's an implicit bias i
have about men hey
you uh
you know the show is only 22 minutes
long right j is for justice for all
oh white people
the aclu found that black people were
3.7 times more likely to be arrested for
marijuana possession than white people
even though their rate of marijuana
usage was comparable they say justice is
for everyone but it's really just for
white people like spf 90.
we really got to speed this up okay fine
buckle up k is for karen duh l is for
laws white people's fubu written for us
by us n is for microaggressions examples
include calling anything ghetto asking
us if we work here or is that your real
hair the receipt said is mine back off n
is for nano aggressions which are just
itty bitty micro aggressions o is for
oppression which is also the name of
mitch mcconnell's cologne
oppression for men available at walmart
next to the guns
p is for police brutality which we all
know disproportionately affects people
of color you know what else
disproportionately affects people of
color juveniles back that ass up it's
like black people sweet caroline no no
no no we do not have time for this
[Music]
q is for being qualified but underpaid
and underemployed r is for reparations
we've asked for them in every way
possible even venmo run me my check am i
mu we didn't forget about the mule i'm
gonna name my dante s is for a savior
complex when white allies feel like they
are god's gift to black people when we
all know god's real gift to black people
is rhythm
no
no
no
okay fine
t is for tokenism that's the idea that
you can only have one model minority in
a group of white people now this
practice is used to pit minority groups
against each other for in an effort for
them to excel in white spaces this is
not to be confused with tolkienism
because there are no minorities in any
lord of the rings movies at all amber
okay
uvw therefore upholding values of
whiteness the idea that white is always
right is ingrained into the fabric of
this country when in reality the only
thing that is always right is the price
and 90 degree angles x is for xenophobia
y is for why aren't we teaching this in
schools why is this country so afraid to
learn from its racist past and progress
into a future where diversity equity and
inclusion are the understood norm and z
is for zebra yay we made it
[Applause]
now see
that wasn't so bad wasn't terry
oh
well
i guess we don't know when tarik will be
back but we do know
the
abcs of white privilege
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you